[Music]  tell me something why is it so hard for  you to kill this man he knew every move  of mine before I made it  I have them right there take the shot  and he'd be gone like a ghost  [Music]  who is he  [Music]  I think I know why as good as you  he is you 25 years ago they made you  from me they chose me because there's  never been anybody like me we have to  end this right now  you have all of his gifts without his  hyena you've made a person out of  another person  then you sent me to killing  you made a choice to do this to me this  thing - you're struggling with its fear  embrace them and then overcome it  of all the people in the world to come  after me why would he send you  [Music]  [Music]  you